would be possible for black to sim to  exchange on a7 everything but it's not  because rk7 i say check  and then the rook is hanging so  kikaru is shaking his head  it's the usual agony when you know the  game is over  yeah you have to calm down  adjust yourself  that you can handle the handshake to  talk to your opponent  go out they might catch you  journalists and fans for autographs and  questions  he's looking for the arbiter what's he  doing  no i think he's just looking around  what's going on with other games he just  want to  wants to know what's going around him  what happened with fabi what happened  with others  where is his standing going to be after  this loss  collecting  strengths to resign  yeah that's tough you will be back to  fifty percent point behind fabi two  points behind the publishing right job  played pretty well i must say  yeah  because okay if you think about it if  nakamura would have win today  he would catch fabi right